this week's episode of film school
fridays is brought to you by
thatkevinsmithclub.com that's right man
if you can't get enough of the sound of
my voice then you could surf on over to
thatkevinsmithclub.com
join up watch wake and bake five days a
week listen to plus one so much more
that
kevinsmithclub.com what are you waiting
for join the club
class is back in session welcome to film
school fridays i'm your host kevin smith
um okay there's a filmmaker out there
ladies and gentlemen who for years
people would uh come up to me and be
like
you know who the mexican you is
um and i'd say
who and they'd be like
guillermo del toro man
and i was like oh
um i'm sure he'd hate to hear that i met
guillermo years later and one of the
first things he said to me and i'm not
going to try to do his acts under his
voice
one of the first things he said to me
was like so many people come up to me
and say that
uh you are the american me which i
thought was actually quite adorable
guillermo del toro
uh is one of uh
our era's greatest
filmmakers bar none dude's got an
oscar to his name but that does not a
great
filmmaker make
um you're talking about somebody whose
uh craft is
so
on point
so beyond
his peers um
in this pier included
he ranks his own category
of film you just you can know
a guillermo del toro film distinctly
watching the opening
30 seconds of it
um it's a signature style and an
interest in subject matter
uh that appeals
to genre enthusiasts
but crosses over to the highbrow to
people who would never watch a movie
about a sea monster for lack of a better
description
having an affair with like a human woman
essentially a version of creature of the
black lagoon man and yet
it won an oscar and that's
not material that's the material in the
right hands
of a true artist to talk about uh his
latest film
which i just found out it shows you what
an idiot i am because i'm watching this
movie gone like this is crazy original
and then somebody the other day was like
to remake bro and i was like what
and then like yeah man there's a there's
a remake this movie actually
like existed at one point and and i just
saw on twitter recently like side by
side
quote unquote frame comparisons between
the first the original film which i
guess is you know available through
criterion
and uh the present film uh nightmare
alley which will be from what i
understand on hbo max
on february 1st
uh if you haven't seen it
and i suspect you have it because this
was a movie i believe that was made by
fox
and then disney of course acquired fox a
minute ago and
disney wound up in control of this film
and you know i
there's a lot of people online will
swear that it was just unceremoniously
dumped by
by the distributor um you know i i
can't speak to that i saw some
billboards but
i honestly i've seen this movie and i
deeply appreciate it
but i i don't know what cell
was gonna penetrate and break through
the mainstream like i i don't
i wouldn't necessarily fault disney
on that uh this is one of those
tough to sell movies um this i when this
movie was done i felt
not that hey it's the same as or
mine is as good as but i felt a kinship
with nightmare alley that was
like i was like oh it's
it's like tusk and as much as like when
when tusk was over people would ask me
like who's that for
and i'm like well for me number one and
i i don't know i hope people
i hope a few people
when i was finished with nightmare alley
that was the thought i had and i didn't
mean that dismissively but i was like
wow like that is
you know tusk is like three million
dollars and even that was probably too
much money
this is a movie that's got like bradley
cooper in it
kate blanchett
uh rooney mara is that how you say your
name um
and some other oh willem dafoe
uh and it's a period piece and it's shot
within an inch of its life and art
directed and uh within an inch of its
life the costumes
are insane
a long way of saying they spent more in
a buck 05 on this picture man like there
was some money spent on this picture so
the
thing that like when the movie was done
you know just guesstimating how much
that cost
there was this feeling of like
well i i get it man i like making movies
for like 10 people but generally i i do
it inexpensively i was like this man
chose his magic moment this is the first
film following his academy award if i
remember correctly
this was his like that you do anything
you want what do you want to do
and he did it he chose to spend his
currency
wisely at the time he did because
i don't know how else this movie would
have gotten made and that again that is
not
to put the movie down i love the movie i
was enthralled by the movie and i'm
haunted by the movie still to this day
so much so that's the third episode of
our
uh this volume of film school fridays
but it is dizzying
to think about the amount of people who
were probably between you know guillermo
pitching this and
making the movie go like are you sure
you want to do this
it's a brave movie
that a filmmaker only a filmmaker
who's at their peak of their game
and uh you know commanding uh the
world's respect and cinema's respect
could get away
with making um that being said i'm glad
he made it man remake or not and i'm
unfamiliar with the original
um
as i said it's a haunting film arresting
uh
not a mystery box as the jj people
call that concept
more just a mystery and slowly unfolding
film noir that
i i had no idea where it was going at
any given point again i didn't watch or
see the original that the this film
remakes
so
you know this for me
was a discovery you know i i knew that
he was making another movie
and not you know i saw the billboards
when it was coming out and stuff
but you know i was not like you know
first in line man it's not marvel movie
so i was like you can wait i'll get
there
and
i'm so glad that like they sent me an
academy screener because one night i
turned to jen and i was like you know
there's this guillermo del toro movie
um she's like what's it about i was like
i have no idea but it's you know
blanchett's in it and i listed the cast
and she was like let's do it
and the two of us
like i didn't get laid that night
because the two of us at the end of the
movie were like
jesus
you know it's the movie is arresting
it's a
it's an assault
to common sense because the things that
happen in it aren't common sensical
um and it's insanely well made and and i
you know i i don't know
guillermo enough to uh lay claim to
to uh uh something like this but feels
very guillermo del toro to me
like feels maybe perhaps the most
outside of pan's labyrinth the most
guillermo del toros thing
um and as much as it looks like he made
something that he loved or remade
something that he loved um
for this episode of film school friday
with the s at the end
um we turn to a guillermo del toro
expert or at least as close as we got
within the vicinity uh coming all the
way
from burbank ladies and gentlemen um
he's an artist that uh
i've been working with um
we did a mall rat show
oh i didn't do them all right there was
a mall rat show at gallery uh 1988 which
is uh
jen's and carbs gallery uh out here
that's a you know wonderful space for
paintings from usually local artists but
now artists from all around the world um
but a very distinct uh subject matter
generally pop culture uh cult films
things like that uh crazy for cult
series that comes out gallery 1988. they
had a mall rat show and there was this
gorgeous uh
these maul rats figures and it was a jay
in silent bob and they were rats
um and there was a piece like a
two-dimensional piece of them together
and uh it was like i loved it so much i
missed the figures somebody else scapped
them up very quickly um i was able to
get the other piece and and fell in love
uh with the artist's work
uh and the artist
is here today he uh does morning rats uh
he has
done
uh uh me as well
uh in
sideshow collectibles has this uh series
of
of plastic toys not just they make those
gorgeous [ __ ] sculptures but
they do plastic toys now as well
and they did a guillermo del toro
um what they call guru and it was a
cartoon version of guillermo and he had
like six arms
and each of our hand of the arm is
holding something that represents
guillermo in his world beautiful piece
and it was at
gallery 1988 guillermo show a full on
just flat out all guillermo del toro
show
uh that was curated
by uh the artist and and our guest today
uh a guy who knows a fair bit about
guillermo
and knows a fair bit about art we're
gonna get to know him and then dive into
nightmare alley at nightmare nightmare
alley uh welcome to the show
one name kids
brandon like a [ __ ] man then the
only name in art that matters one name
chogrin how are you my friend oh thanks
for having me kevin that was quite an
introduction
very very special and humbled tell the
kids uh who you are give me your bona
fides uh so they uh know where you're
coming at uh with all this guillermo
stuff you're not just a guy who's like i
like guillermo del toro moves obviously
you are but you're more than that tell
them about the the show that you curated
and the guru so um my name is chogran
i'm an artist and storyteller i've been
working in the industry for the last 10
years and you know i've been inspired by
artists like you guillermo and it's
funny before we get into it i just want
to say that it's hilarious that people
said that you were the mexican guillermo
because i i mean that was the first
thing i wanted to say at the beginning
of this podcast is that both of you are
so alike that i'm it would be amazing
for you to have them on the podcast just
for the fact that you are both
ex-catholics yeah and you both get high
on your own supply
very true the only difference between us
other than uh the geographical one is uh
he is
crazy [ __ ] talented born to be a
filmmaker a vid not just a filmmaker but
visual stylist because it goes beyond
film for him yeah yeah um you're you're
a different kind of filmmaker though i
mean i just like tourists you have you
have the heart you got to have that
passion because otherwise you know if
you don't have that passion you don't
make it in this business it's true but
he's got the heart and he also has the
eye
you know or the eyes that are on hands
that cover somebody's what he likes to
call eye protein
is that what it is yeah because you know
he says that in his films there and a
lot of films have eye candy he likes to
put i pro protein where it's kind of
like you're telling a story but without
saying anything you know you're putting
like little props in the background that
are kind of either adding to the
character or just like telling a whole
other story in itself like another layer
so i met him years ago probably a decade
back
i get probably around pans maybe a
little before before pans even
jeff robinov who used to run warner
brothers um was having a party for his
kid and
and uh me and jen stopped by and
guillermo i think it was when he you
know dropped
weight because he's he's like me he's
gone up down up down and stuff so it was
one of the first times where it was like
hey man what happened to half of you and
stuff
so i met him and he like smoked right
over to me
and was so chatty and cheerful that's
when he told me the
i'm the american they tell me i'm the
american you oh
such a lovely dude and
you know we chit-chatted for like 20
minutes there and you could tell i was
like oh my god and i say you even said i
was like i do a podcast man you got to
come on and he was like i would love to
and that was mind you a decade back like
time flies
um
but uh yeah he
he's he's got a similar
energy you know there was a very like
well i was kind of like looking in a
mirror effect to it right down to the
even the shape of us and the facial hair
and the
the like you know
when we speak about movies and cinema
it's with passion he has a lot more
erudition than i do he's he's like a
quentin in as much as like he sees i
mean he must have
like here proof positive i don't even
know nightmare alley was another movie
yeah uh no uh i think i think both of
you um like like i mean there's a reason
why i'm doing a guru of him and you know
there's a compliment right there um yeah
he
the first movie that i saw of his in
theaters and this is the this is the how
i both got into hellboy and uh and
guillermo del toro was blade too i saw
blade two in the theater that's right
that was him now who did blade one not
him uh steve norrington so he comes and
takes over blade too and yeah you know
the blade one had the shower scene that
everybody remembers but blade too had
this like crazy
action it had to it had the reaper and
it was almost basically from i remember
watching the special features it was
kind of like his movie to prove that he
could do hellboy he could do a superhero
movie he wanted to be like look because
this is the one i really believe in i
want to do mignola's hellboy but look i
could do this and this was 2002. you
know like the superhero move 20 years
ago yeah i know i know this year during
the dark period for the superhero movie
like between the batman between batman
and robin and the resurgence of like say
x-men like i i put blade as the
beginning of the research
movie but
by the time you get to x-men spider-man
that's when it's like spider-man
spider-man that's when you get to like
otis shits here to stay it's no longer a
fluke or a one-off and stuff but that's
true i forgot that he did
blade too and it was just so visually
arresting and
like it i'm certainly i'm not lowering
one to raise one to lower another but
you know in a world where you're like
all right you're not the director of
blade the original blade you're stepping
into it and you already
got a filmmaking career of your own
you've already established
yourself yeah um
i remember that movie popping and i
remember at the time people being like
oh like blade 2 is actually really good
man and the director
is who's doing it that's he's that's
what's you know where it's coming from
it was very it was very comic book-y um
as opposed to the first one the first
one is rad uh because this guy like
still has
exploding vampires and stuff like it
like guillermo took from everything from
the first one and put it like on speed
dial right you know um and also you know
adding i don't know if you ever got into
his series the strain but he loves every
guillermo del toro movie will have like
a big anatomy or a dissection thing so
he loves like creating these kind of
creatures so the vampires in the movie
were called the reapers and like you
know super intricate like their whole
mouth opens up uh anyways um
fast forward from watching the theater
and then i saw the special features on
dvd from the blade too because that's
the only reason you really need to buy
dvds back then just because of the
special features i remember the dogma
one
um there were many film schools bad like
there's a whole generation rodriguez
grew up watching the special features
particularly the lord of the rings
features
in the field yeah so in that in those uh
in those special features um he he was
talking about blade but half the time he
was talking about hellboy
and he very very like
uh
you know there's little hellboy easter
eggs like norman reedus is wearing a
bprd shirt like in the movie
so so it's kind of so i was like oh who
says like a demon who's wearing goggles
you know and immediately went to the
comic book store and that kind of
started a whole love affair with between
del toro and mignola so now like i never
had a superhero uh
that i could call like my own like
everybody's like oh my favorite superior
spider-man for me hellboy was that that
moment i was like this is my guy so this
that's the the guy that i exclusively
collect superhero wise and he and
oddly enough it was like a filmmaker who
got you into the character yep yep yep
yep yeah and i actually that's one of
the things i um
i uh i tweeted the there was a tweet
back and forth with me between me and
him and i said uh congratulations to the
nightmare alley and i just said uh you
know now i'm still hope crossing my
fingers for hellboy three finish finish
off the trilogy i want to go back and do
the one with ron right i mean i don't
know if he does but i want
so i mean we live in an age where we got
freaking ghostbusters three yeah in a
sense so no i don't i'm not gonna say
it's not possible anything's possible
now you know um it's because i thought
after the you know the 2016 ghostbusters
like oh we're done yeah that's it we'll
never see it again and then you know
here we are and then now it's like oh my
god they can keep going yeah absolutely
um you're bona fide is an art you went
to you're from uh philly area and you
went to where where's whiskey i went to
the university of the arts in philly um
which is where um uh usq another usq
alumni uh teaches there dave dineen dave
dineen is the guy who
if you ever looked at buddy christ
you're looking at the face of dave
dineen yeah he was the artist
who was a rat face robert holtzman our
production designer
tapped him his friend dave's name he
said hey man can you make the betty
craze statue first this is what it has
to look like
based on the script
and uh you know dave denim went out and
bought this old marble statue
of jesus oh that's right he cut off the
arms and cut off the arms and the head
which is almost sacrificed because his
face it's literally dave and it's dave's
face he he basically sculpted his own
face as the face of jesus the winking
jesus buddy christ yeah that is the face
of dave dineen you can search the
picture online yeah i posted it it's
also interesting it's also in your book
it's in the book as well that's right
secret stash um it's it's hysterical
because there's dave standing right next
to the buddy christ doing the same exact
pose and you can see he just made
himself jesus adorable so he teaches at
that school yeah i believe so uh last
time i checked i mean i now i'm getting
to the point where i'm like oh i've been
away from school for a while for a
minute but he used to at that point he
used to yeah i think he was uh in film
and animation i never had i i never had
the you know um i heard he was just an
awesome teacher so you know where in a
weird way i felt like i missed out but i
always heard the stories like oh yeah he
did the buddy christ in dogma and then
uh also um ted biaselly who i don't know
very well but i interacted with him here
and there because we're both huge motu
fans um he went to uarts as well back in
the day like you knew him no no i didn't
interact just from just from being in
the industry and i was like oh you know
like alumni you know because sometimes i
send a newsletter i'm like hey this
guy's doing this and i was like oh cool
so and so i you know i was like dude
like you're like part of the
responsible for bringing masters back
and by the way let me go on record that
your master's is amazing you doug thank
you thank you wow
it's always nice to hear that coming up
from coming from a kid coming from a kid
look at the rings he's got a [ __ ]
skeletor ring has a grey skull ring and
what's the [ __ ] he-man ring yeah this
is frankenstein but these two yeah yeah
uh i got grayskull and skeletons
um
ted went to school there as well yeah
yeah yeah when did you
come from the east coast to the west
coast you've been out here in california
how long oh my gosh and now more than a
little bit over 11 years what did you
come out for for um i came to work for
animation i i had originally when i was
going to school in philly i went to um
study illustration but i knew that my
end goal was to be able to tell
my stories through animation and you
know storyteller film
um so you've got a style your specific
art style
presumably
one day you make your own cartoon it
looks like that right it's gonna look
like your stuff yeah and my style i
should say is very much inspired by um
the flyshire cartoons uh old rubber hose
animation uh abbay works who
i i gotta give a shout out to because he
doesn't get enough love he was the
co-creator of mickey mouse
um you say him
i think it might have been pronounced
oob but i always thought like when i
read it because it really i believe it's
spelled ubi
yeah you know
it was like
you be like
but it's he's the guy who co-created
mickey mouse yeah and he was literally
when i think because they lost the
rights to oswald he was literally
animating uh uh i think i believe
everybody knows it's you know uh uh
steamboat willie but i think it was
plain crazy the one that he was like he
was still working at universal like
under contract and he was animating like
i think something ridiculous like 700
pages a day oh so
so you know he made i every time i i go
to disneyland i i always want to be like
there should be a statue of that guy oh
that guy because especially in
california adventure it's walt from the
1920s i'm like i should be writing it
right next to and also it's like in a
world where they brought oswald back and
made a big [ __ ] deal about like he's
back it's like all right how about you
yeah i can honor the guy that the human
being there's a there's a uh
you know of course walt disney
everywhere a big walt is he statue in
disney world and disneyland but yeah in
uh at the disney lot
there's a roy disney statue yep yep and
you would feel like
yeah he got up man he got one he got one
that's the statue that's featured in
walt disney world he got one because
he's the one that finished the park the
florida park for walt so it was kind of
like finishing his dream you know but
yeah i
wholeheartedly agree and that's actually
something i wanted i said it you know if
you ever do something more with movies
origins i would love to see a kind of
like a nancy goldruff and somebody else
that
well
i think they did because i wanted to
kind of uh grow more as an artist
there's actually a whole book that was
released by his son and his
granddaughter who's an amazing
documentarian herself leslie i worked
and she like every every documentary
you've seen on pixar or like you know
the imagineering that's all done by her
so uh kind of sort of like when did his
own thing for almost i think i want to
say 10 years and then came back to
disney but then
can i swear
the [ __ ] created like a lot of
the innovations that disney uses today
like the 360 camera like that remember
that space where you could you could go
into a room and you could like see a
thing in 360. he invented that kind of
camera he invented the the xerox method
for 101 dalmatians that's 101 dalmatians
you can see like the pencil line of the
animators yeah yeah so which made it
kind of like look a little bit like i
don't want to say cheaper but it kind of
gave the animators liked it because they
could see more of their they're working
their hand they also give it more
personal touch so he came back not as an
animator he came back basically as an
inventor so he had kind of had like he
was a guy that always challenged himself
once he mastered something it was like
next to the next thing to the next thing
to the next thing he was just one of
those guys that was just like amazing
just like he had that spirit of like
next next so he did go back to disney
and him him and walt did have like a
real consulate uh
um and uh so yeah he's a big influence
for me he did uh he had his own
characters flip the frog willy wopper
those are his styles huge influence on
me and then besides the uh all the in
popeye ec seaguar all those guys but
besides that i have a huge influence on
japanese animation because growing up
vice versa japanese inflation animation
has a huge influence on you yeah yes yes
um guys like ozamo tezuka
which are kind of like they were
influenced by classic disney and it's
like and now we're influenced by anime
so it's like a big circle
um but um growing up in south america
ecuador um i'm so glad that you know i
was exposed to a lot of that stuff
because we were getting you grew up in
ecuador in ecuador yeah i grew up in
guayaquil i was born and raised in
waikiki ecuador and then i moved to this
to the to philly when i was like 13.
so
were you was some in you're probably you
grow up fluent in english as well my mom
my mom was american so i kind of had i
was one of those kids growing up that
nobody could understand what the [ __ ] i
was saying like until i was like maybe
four or five where i was like oh this is
english and this is you had to separate
the two oh my god god could you imagine
you don't have to imagine like bro i
lived it yeah so living here in la is
[ __ ] great because it's like oh it's
like a combination of both those worlds
right both philly and you know ecuador
so and the weather is great so when you
moved to like pennsylvania there was no
like oh man i didn't know how to speak
you could
communicate there were some barriers
like slang you know like i i you know um
curse words and things like that but uh
your movies helped me with that
how were the the folks in the delco area
to an ecuadorian 13 year old boy who
moves into the neighborhood um well i
didn't well i should i should rephrase i
moved to philly when i went to college
so the town that i moved into was like
this uh coin i i like to call it the
shire
basically there's like three things to
do golf mini golf bowling in the theater
i think every small americana you can
see hobbits doing all that [ __ ]
so there's a very heartwarming feeling
every time what is the name of the town
uh danville pennsylvania i went to
danville high school um and then i went
to university of arts in philly i lived
with my uncle because he lived in philly
so it was um
and going back into the i lived in the
city in ecuador so moving into philly
later on didn't felt more like home how
weird was it then to go from a city to
like danville
um
the shire the shire yeah it i think i
think because of the you know it was a
period of time where you know it was
like that coming of age 13. um i'm i'm
just very glad and thankful for my mom
for just encouraging me like to do keep
keep me busy because you know it's that
age where you could like either go like
you know i don't know crazy or
and i was just i i was going through a
lot and you know i didn't realize like
making new friends a lot of stuff so i
was just a nerd like i was the i was the
kid like you know there would people be
getting drunk at their houses you know
like hey my parents are gone like you
know throwing a party i'm like sorry i
can't make it i gotta tape dragon ball z
at four
and i like to tape it without
commercials
i just sit there and pause vhs yeah so
so i was that kid and uh you know going
to art school um
yeah i just kind of you know met a bunch
of other mutants you know like myself
and and then i came out to the big uh
capital of mutants
what animated shows did you work on when
you came out you worked for comedy for
cartoon network yeah i worked on uh
adventure time and regular shows oh two
shows that everybody hates and nobody
ever heard of what does it like working
on adventure time it was fun man i mean
i had seen the pilot um before i became
at the adventure time so i was already a
fan and so coming into it like to be
actually part of the production i
started out as a pa so and then i worked
my way up to production coordinator and
then i actually landed uh an artist's
position joined the animation union all
that jazz and
became part of regular show but the
whole journey was just kind of amazing
because you know being in the studio you
get to meet different people like there
was one time
i'll tell this story because i know
you'll appreciate it one time i had to
give a guided tour around around the
around the studio to a bunch of students
and uh coming out of the recording
studio is [ __ ] mark hamill oh [ __ ]
and it was like around the time when
they were about to shoot uh force
awakens so he was like all trim and you
know like and and he had like a you know
you could tell he had like a renaissance
you know he was looking at his best yeah
yeah and then he didn't know me at all
like i had seen him a couple of times
from recordings but he would he
literally stopped pointed he saw that i
was about to start giving a tour and he
said like this guy right here he's gonna
give you a great time
i was like
and then i literally turned around to
them i was like the tour is not going to
get any better
yes that was the highlight
so
it was kind of like a moment like hey
hey everybody mark hamill applause so um
yeah um so yeah i've had little moments
like that it got into me a lot of really
cool people through the voice recording
gotten to me a lot of heroes um while
being out here one of the one of the
side things that i did that i that i
still do every once in a while is art
galleries and through art galleries is
where i've met a lot of like different
artists that i collaborate with um i got
to do that you know curate the guillermo
show
and in that guillermo show i did um
i did this uh you know piece called guru
del toro and uh eventually that ended up
you know being a toy pitch did a
sideshow during uh under their unruly um
banner and which is basically kind of
like leaning towards independent artists
and uh that's really cool and then they
were like hey man um who else do you
like uh that would be a good guru and
they meet you were like immediately on
top of those i was like uh kevin smith
and tim burton nice
that's good company so tim burton's body
not gonna happen because there's no i
don't think there's even a funko pop of
him is that right yeah don't go for that
because that's usually how we go like
i'm like if there's a funko pop then
there's a chance
so
so i was very happy that you know when
uh when i pitched uh uh you and you know
we got to make it my only
my only uh i i think it would have been
on balance but i wish i we i could have
put a [ __ ] knocker hand
but i think it would have been too uh
you know
the piece is gorgeous they could see a
two-dimensional rendering of it yeah
like where's the they could buy the
print at sideshow collectibles i don't
know if they're still there yeah yeah
yeah the print is kind of i think it's
not a it's like oh you can get guru del
toro uh and the print there they're
still available the print uh was is all
me my 2d design and then
from that 2d design a sculptor came in
and i kind of gave as much notes to my
liking and then they were like okay
approved and then there's going to be
like you know three variants coming out
uh date i don't have dates but there's
going to be an edible edition which is
going to be oh it's called readable
which is red right there's going to be a
dope variant which is going to be
flocked it's all going to be all green
which is actually i want to put next to
my moss man
and and then the the regular edition
which is the clerk's black and whites
that's the you know that's the for me
yeah that's the one i'm gonna have next
to my guillermo so i'm gonna have all
three i'm a big kevin smith fan
hey man let me just jump in here for a
sec to remind you
jsonbob.com ladies and gentlemen you
want to buy anything clerks related
anything jay and salam bob related
anything kevin smith related go to jay
and
silentbob.com now back to the show
when you curated the guillermo show did
he go yeah he went he went yeah so did
you get to meet him at the show i had
met him a couple of times like at small
smaller venues like dark dark delicacies
you know the horror book shop in burbank
they're they're great um he did a
signing there so over the years he just
kind of like grew this rapport with him
and uh and then after this he actually
owns the original one because that i did
for the art show so then years later
you know through like twitter i was like
hey man do you mind if like we make this
into a toy he's like fine by me
so i kind of you know kind of went with
a blessing like that and i think you
know then i got approvals elsewhere but
uh yeah he's great and i also did um a
children's book based on his childhood
called the kid del toro get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah yeah where can they find
them that's uh published through little
libros so and now i feel bad for
swearing
oh the poor little libras yeah um
that's adorable man what is it called
kid delta
kid del toro yeah yeah um i i think if i
remember correctly
my first exposure to guillermo's work
guillermo directed minotaur didn't he
chronos
kronos yeah
which is which is cool because you both
you 1994 sundance yeah he did i think
his came out 93 but you were you know
you guys were like basically like around
the same time it was yeah but yeah he
did kronos was kind of his like you know
that everybody started paying attention
to yes like it was around the same time
as clerks like i remember
because i was working at miramax
and then he wound up doing mimic mimic
at dimension over the course of what
felt like a [ __ ] decade because
bob kept going like
we getting we work it and he kept going
back and making
guillermo re-shoot and re-shoot like i
always felt bad for guillermo because
it's like you're taking like one of the
premier talents yeah and you're treating
him like a workhorse but you know what
he said that because of that experience
that experience um made him learn to say
no is that right i say no but it also
like taught him how to like basically
just kind of work like
when somebody gives you notes just kind
of like how to like you know i think
work doing dolly shots getting more like
doing experimenting and things like that
so then he took that experience you know
and uh because i think they wanted him i
think to do blade too immediately after
that and he knew that he needed to make
like a personal move for himself first
before he went on to do something so he
did devil's backbone right after that oh
that's right i forgot about that
and the devil's backbone well we'll
we'll get into this but devil's backbone
and uh pence labyrinth are kind of uh
companion films are they really because
they both take place during the spanish
civil war
oh [ __ ] yeah good point and what's crazy
is that
um
the author of nightmare alley william
gresham um
wrote got the inspiration for nightmare
alley during the civil war
the spanish civil war so nightmare alley
begins its life as a book first yes yes
then a feature yep and then years later
yeah the del toro's movie yeah it
started uh it was written by william
gresham in 1946 from his experience
during the spanish civil war of talking
to um a carnival worker and which is
basically him just kind of like
documenting like just the you know like
the behind the scene how the sausage is
made basically right so he literally put
that in the book and then a year later
tyrone power buys the rights and makes
it you know into this movie and at the
time i think it was like uh sanic it was
one of those producers like in fox and
um
he
tyrone power wanted to do it originally
because he wanted to get away he he was
known for his like romance and
swashbuckler like roles and he wanted to
do something serious like he wanted to
play like this like you know like grimy
like character that was like you know
had like two sides almost so uh the the
the role that's played by bradley cooper
is played by tyrone power uh stan i said
what is it stan
stan carl car stan carl oh my gosh i
forgot already uh but um so that movie
was made and and if you actually watch
both movies
uh they're pretty pretty close uh you
were you were saying that you know
they're kind of but the ending is
different the ending they couldn't do
the the the sad ending uh back then in
47.
so and so
the ending that i mean we'll get into
[ __ ] yeah spoilers right we can talk
spoilers absolutely we'll get in the
nightmare alley but they the current
incarnation of nightmare
alley the ending is
to
bleak to say the least well that the
other black and white one is more a
triumphant ending well it still has stan
turning into a geek you know still has
him like you know like that scene where
like you know and i think in that
version
he says mister i will i was made for it
and in del toro's version it's mister i
was born for it and it was i think they
did born in the new one because it was
sadder right you know but in so
after that he actually goes to the
carnival that he started out in and he
actually meets up molly finds pete pity
in him and they kind of sort of you know
uh make amends right right right before
he turns full geek
so that was the ending of the original
original one yeah and this one is just
but that was a studio demand because
tyrone power wanted that bleak they
wanted that bleak ending like the new
one how does del toro get to this movie
was he a fan of it or they come to him
and be like hey what about this i think
i think it was always a dream project
but like you said it was one of those
things where kind of like you kind of
have to have like the right your chips
at the right place at the right time and
i'm sure because i know his other dream
projects as uh love crabs at the
mountains of madness so i'm sure for him
after a shape of water he's like i
either do mountains or i do
nightmare alley and you know he chose
nightmare alley and what's amazing you
said that it's the most del toro del
toro movie and you're right because most
of the tour movies the monsters are not
the monsters the monsters are the humans
yeah so
um yeah it is the most mastery
uh del toro movie i mean movie's
gorgeous i saw it both in black and
white they're doing you saw the black
and white ones yeah i saw black and
white where are they doing it at the uh
new bev quentin's got theater out here
um that uh only screens 35 millimeter
prints yeah so
um guillermo must have requested that
they spit out a 35 millimeter black and
white print well yeah and i think that
was one of his requests like um because
there was a q a afterwards and one of
the things that he said was like i think
the movie was originally like three
hours and change and then the studio
said like okay cut it down but he said
okay if i cut it down then can you you
know fi i think it would finance or just
kind of make can you give me a black and
white version right because that's
expensive yeah yeah i'm sure it used to
be very cheap back in the day to strike
another print right as long as you had
your negative you could drag as many
prints as possible and
a couple grand for print
now when you create a print
um from the film that's you know coming
out of a digital medium essentially it's
one long effect shot
so you have to render
the movie onto film and becomes like
insanely costly the um
we didn't have a print on
tusk you know because we were in the
digital era and stuff yeah quentin
wanted to screen it
as part of michael parks week at the at
the new beverly yeah and uh
he asked he was like would you mind if i
haven't strike a print and i was like oh
my god go ahead especially when i saw
the price tag i was like [ __ ] better
you and me yeah [ __ ] you pay for it
go ahead that's awesome um so wow what
was the black and white like i i mean of
course the original was in black and
white i saw the one i watched was
beautiful lush
color muted of course but
uh you know period film for those uh
before we dive in
for those unfamiliar with the story uh
uh
nightmare alley tells uh the tale of um
uh stan carlisle yeah let me i just
wanted to stan carlisle who is winds up
working at a circus
yeah
carnival yeah um and he's a drifter
right he's a drifter he kind of starts
out like yeah just kind of intimated
that he killed
i mean more than intimated but
throughout the movie you learned that he
like uh killed his
father his father and the and the art
book is literally called the the rice
and false done carlisle so the movie is
literally you get to see this this
person who has good intentions like has
that american dream has like you know
but you know the movie the movie also is
basically painting the underbelly of the
american dream you know the because
because i you know i can see that
happening especially when you live out
here in hollywood you know like like
you're like it's never enough like the
next thing the next thing the next thing
is like you're always like going after
like filling that void and you know this
is kind of that cautionary tale of like
yeah man you gotta don't cross the line
stan cross stan goes beyond crossing the
line
he picks up
various carny trade while hanging out
and then he wants to make a run at
like doing a mesmerization act or with
mind reading mental activity intellect
yeah and so um
and uh tony collette tells them that's
that's fine but never go into a spook
show
yeah never cross the line the spook show
is basically like when you're telling
people like oh yeah your loved one's
here and we see we see the cause and
effect of the bad thing of that because
then we see uh mary steinberg's
character killing killing herself at the
end just so they can be with their son
because he says like you'll be with your
son when you you know pass away
eventually he's like all right well so
that's what she meant is like don't do
the spook show yeah don't do the spook
show just you know don't because you're
basically
you can see that's the that's the
beautiful thing about this movie about
del toro's movies is like their charac
the characters are never
you know unless they're you know they're
a fascist like you know the one and past
library but the characters are never
fully black and white there's always a
lot of gray and you can see in bradley
cooper's portrayal that
um
he does kind of have good intentions he
what does want to give people hope but
then mixed in with the greed you know of
making money then it starts getting
wishy wishy-washy but yeah she that's
what she says like you know don't do
this book show because that's when it
starts getting because remember there's
a one scene where tony collette like
reads the crowd and tells the ladies
like oh i can feel my brother
hand and shoulder and then after right
after the show she kind of has to tell
her like hey no like you know it's part
of the trick yeah yeah like stan just
kind of was like goes full he goes with
it and to dire consequences later on
there's a sequence where
um he's talking to
uh mary steve urgent who's lost her kid
and you know
saying like oh yeah the kid's here and
he's communicating and he's telling you
this and
it's a very yeah generally speaking the
act that he has going with
uh is
are they married or no yeah she marries
she's married but the thing is she's
married to like a big figure in the city
like to one of the judges
so because they you hear on the radio as
soon as it happens like you know and
right before that other character played
by um
uh
uh
man i'm blanking but the other guy that
dies
uh the other rich guy
cooper punches his
brains out so
but so he winds up with rooney mara and
they come up with this like
elaborate code system yeah
in order for him to keep a blindfold on
and you know what am i holding and
based on the words he's
able to say and and and people are oh it
has fun parlor tricks and then
periodically yeah there are people who
are like you know talk to the spirits my
is my brother here and
that's what the tony collette character
who works the carnival as well was kind
of telling them like don't get into that
yeah like you crossing the line and
i thought
when she was doing that i was like oh
you know this del toro's gonna be some
spooky [ __ ] yeah there's no supernatural
in this movie well yeah from what i for
one from i think what guillermo said
briefly after the q a he said that they
did shoot like this monster sequence but
it was a nightmare that that uh stan
sent but they they cut it out took it
out
it's normally you know there are
monsters at play uh they're you know um
supernatural elements at work in in uh
gamma's uh flicks
but this is just
greed avarice like the seven deadly sins
that kind of make men monsters yeah yeah
and i you know and that's one of the
things that i think he likes he always
says in a lot of his stuff is he doesn't
there's no such thing as a perfect human
being he always likes to say we we are
the most unperfect [ __ ] that
you know that there are and i think
that's why he always you know makes like
the you know like the fascist leader in
pence labyrinth like you know because
they there's like
trying to go towards like that
perfection that doesn't it's like an
illusion you know so i feel like stan
you know stan is kind of like the same
it's just kind of sort of like yeah and
when i get to this thing and you know
like it'll everything will be fine it
just but just doesn't stop you know it
just keeps going and going a couple
different movies at play in this movie
yeah because it starts as like the
drifter movie and then it becomes a
carnival movie and then you think all
right we're gonna be carnival movie
forever and then it moves into high
society
um and then it moves into
psychiatry
yeah well yeah they introduced the cate
blanchett character who like starts
getting into
um his head and his and his bed as well
um but very
she's unraveling
him yeah you know as much as he plays
people and he's falling for it so it's
kind of like a like a like a double like
you know because she he kind of sort of
like embarrasses her at that show it's
like all right [ __ ]
yeah i'm gonna go she challenges him
kind of publicly by you know don't yeah
you know she she won't let uh the
assistant say anything describe it she
wants him to
describe to call it without any prompts
or any help yeah because she thinks he's
a fraud but he manages to kind of escape
by and embarrass her yeah um
and i guess
that's enough for her to be like well
i'm going to destroy this [ __ ]
yeah because that's
what slowly happens
like throughout the
third act then all of a sudden you're in
the midst of this film noir yeah um
kind of throwback and then i mean the
way that she shot like i think that uh
cinematographer dan lauson just got
nominated um just because movie's
getting nominated for all sorts of words
just today got a costume nomination i
i i bet you he winds up getting a dga
nomination because this is a movie that
like even though it didn't nobody seems
to be talking about it
in the mainstream i mean they will be as
of february 1st once it's on hbo max or
whatever
but i think a lot of people in the
industry
are talking about it they're kind of
going for it and
because it's just you're like this is
ballsy you know
you take a cast like that yeah and a
budget like that and you make one of the
bleakest [ __ ] art house films that
have ever been made but i mean but i
mean i think that's the torah's whole
stick is he said he says that he has
like the worst uh time being a pitch man
because all his stories all the stories
he wants to tell i mean look at i mean i
don't wanna i don't know what hellboy
three would be about if it ever gets
made but i mean spoiler alert he dies in
the comic
cowboy does yeah hillary does yeah and
so that's what he finally becomes the
beast of the apocalypse like
so we think that that's
been where he would have taken like the
third one oh yeah absolutely yeah
because uh the end at the end of the
second one uh the the bastard [ __ ]
[ __ ] teased everybody with a little uh
epilogue at the end of the art book and
it wasn't in the movie but if you got
the art book you're like and rasputin
comes back and all this i was like you
son of a [ __ ]
i want to see that movie right now
um
and uh
and yeah so i mean but then mountains of
madness is about it's basically the
thing you know a group of scientists out
in the arctic and they all get killed
only but one and the one comes back and
tells the story
yeah so i mean those are i i i you know
the story is i think if del toro makes
any other movies here's my wish list i
want to see his version of frankenstein
nice i want to see mountains and i want
to see hellboy 3. after that i'll i can
die happy
the wish list um um the uh
i mean i was trying to think back to
mimic i guess they forced a happy ending
on him there too yeah well he he i think
you know now that after his shape of
water when he became like a little bit
more well-known they finally released a
director's cut yeah a mimic yeah yeah he
finally got some justice on it yeah yeah
where is he from uh guadalajara uh
mexico um where's where is that in
relation to
uh my mexican
my mexican friends please don't kill me
i think i think it's in relation it's
closer to mexico city
in the center he's buddies with um
the trio yeah there's the three of them
and who's the the guy one guy who did
the revenant right right right
and then uh who's the third one
oh yeah um did they all know each other
or they're just like oh we're three
filmmakers from the same kind of i think
i think him and cuaron actually went to
school together
okay so there's that's that's a funny
story because like they um
the way they learned film is um
they basically got to do their version
of the twilight zone growing up in
mexico but they kind of just literally
because like they always say like yeah
it was like it was like this shitty
version of the twilight zone is it but
it was it was a great learning uh was it
a tv show yeah it was called i think oda
marikada
which is the uh the
the marked time you know so it was an
anthology program yeah yeah so he and
you know guillermo did a lot of things
guillermo i think you know it's funny
he's been very true to um because the
children's book that i wrote is about
how
um it was inspired by a story that he um
he would pee his bed and like
he's good
yeah because he saw because his i i
guess let me set it up better his
brother his brother had scared him from
uh i guess it was like an episode of the
uh
the outer limits that was called the
mutant with like this guy with big eyes
so ever since then he started seeing
like you know he was scared of like the
dark and he started seeing monsters he
actually saw i think i mean i'm
paraphrasing but he saw actually saw
like the the fawn that it's in pan's
library coming out of the shadows in his
room if i was a kid i'd like be
[ __ ] yourself never mind
so he basically you know like he was
afraid to go to the bathroom and that's
why so he uh his whole the story is
really sweet because he basically said
to the monsters when i like if you let
me go to the bathroom i'll be your
friend forever
so you know and that's kind of sort of
has been his promise is like you know
put monsters in movies it's a beautiful
little story yeah oh my god that's sweet
um so oh man i i went off a tangent and
it was like related to what i wanted to
say oh so
going back to chronos he literally um
from doing all these kind of commercial
works and things like that he literally
started his own special effects company
in mexico just so he could do chronos
and as soon as chronos was done he shut
it down but he learned from all these
different guys like in the industry like
you know like i know uh for e ackerman
was one of his heroes uh bob burns who
has like you know the original the
original original skeleton uh from king
kong king kong and chris ackerman is a
guy who published famous monsters of
film land he was like
the original
fan for he was fanboy he was the
original cave uh you know like the
caveman in the room um and uh what was
called the akker mansion yeah mansion
and uh and guillermo learned from the
this artist uh the special effects
makeup artist called dick smith yeah and
uh he's the legend who worked on
exorcist i believe yep yep yeah did all
all that amazing stuff and uh yeah so
you know i think gamo's been very true
to his you know
to his uh his deal with the monsters
yeah
um in cate blanchett shows up shifts the
movie into this film noir thing
um and there's a scam one last scam that
they're running on
a very wealthy
higher up muckety-muck played by what's
as [ __ ] richard farnsworth maybe richard
jenkins richard jenkins sorry uh the guy
who was in shape of water and got
nominated and stuff yeah um
he
uh wants uh bradley cooper to
communicate with his
dead wife dead girl like a ex flame
explain yeah who who like it is hinted
at that she had an abortion like he
forced her to have an abortion that's
why she's kind of like painted in blood
like in that area down there
and stuff like that so um so he kind of
has this regret but then you find out
that the character has been mean that's
just to that woman oh it's crazy he has
well i mean it's the scam that you know
bradley cooper has
his has rooney
mars showing up in the snowy graveyard
because richard jenkins is getting tired
he's like i think you're a fraud you're
charlatan like you better show me proof
that she's here and you're talking to
her and yeah so
he organizes it sets it up that it's
late at night they're by the grave and
rooney's going to come in the outfit her
hair done like the picture image drawing
of
of this
dead girl and she's got blood kind of
been down below the waist and stuff um
and he's meant to see her from a
distance and and be so scared and then
she would disappear again right by like
set yeah like nothing basically nothing
goes to plan and they go oh no he goes
and grabs her and then he finds out that
she's real and then he sees that it's
not her and then he realizes he's being
played
and
you know instantly [ __ ] turns and you
learned right before she showed up
you know as he was talking to bradley
cooper
rambling you find out that he's a
monster he's probably killed many
[ __ ] women and uh you know
suddenly bradley cooper's it's too late
to pull back
with what's going on and then everything
goes foul they wind up um killing him
right yeah he basically he's like
because in the in the book version uh he
doesn't kill him but he goes through a
whole period where they're basically
chasing making his life miserable
they're chasing him so in the movie
version i think just to kind of make it
you know simple and clean clean they're
just [ __ ] like you're dying bro so
howdy goes and then they go
running
and his bodyguard gets run over like
really oh man that's the one thing i
will say about guillermo's movies like i
as much as i'm a huge fan and i look
forward to them that some of the death
scenes are [ __ ] brutal like i just
like it takes me a couple of times
watching it to just like i wince a
couple of times because and that comes
from him growing like just the reality
of growing up in mexico just seeing dead
bodies all the time you know like just
like i guess you're right i hadn't
thought about that brutality i mean even
me growing up in ecuador like there was
like newspapers like with dead bodies
like you know like and nudity like right
there you know so
um
it's gotta show up in the work yeah yeah
so i mean it was it's part of the
culture um you know um
yeah latin america man where it's it's
weird oh but
one of the things that i appreciate and
i always always kind of relate to
guillermo's work is like you know the
paranormal and things like that are not
things that are like you know like
no it's part of the culture it's like
you know like oh i was talking to my
dead grandmother last night like oh oh
oh what did she say you know that's
great you say that to somebody here
you're like oh you're [ __ ] crazy
you got 50 150 of this [ __ ] yeah
so um what a beautiful thought you're
right man that's true there's like an
acceptance of spirituality in the
culture that like here is just like what
are you nuts but um
there's something magical about that the
idea of like
you know death sucks but like
there's
here it's like death's the end
and you know but you still have the
memories but
i would much rather be like you know oh
i spoke to my
grandmother yeah and live in that world
where people see that as pragmatic
practical and not weird at all like of
course like if people commune with
spirits yeah um the he uh
kate blanche rooney mara goes uh away
from bradley cooper she's out enough
bradley cooper goes to get a pile of
money
from kate blanchet because he's you know
she was the one that fed him the
information yeah we should also set up
that the reason that they kind of sort
of like teamed up and the reason why he
kind of started doing these spook shows
because he had all this freaking
information because she recorded the
sessions all the sessions that she had
with people so she he was able to give
this guy enough juicy enticing details
yeah ammunition so he comes back to
collect the cash and
she you know in a very film noir fashion
turns on him with a [ __ ] gun and and
uh tries to kill him changes all the
bills to one to ones to once yeah he
opens it up and he's like what is this
and she's
just cold-hearted killer at heart and of
course del toro she just doesn't shoot
him she shoots shoot something he has
like a gory ear oh [ __ ] so nasty man
she shot like half his ear off and [ __ ]
yeah he goes uh he gets away and goes
running and and you know winds up living
under bridges and
jumping trains and stops looking like
clean-cut guillermo
bradley cooper yeah um and more like a
hobo
until ultimately he winds up at a
carnival yeah another carnival yeah and
he goes full circle and then what's
crazy and i just there's a show we
didn't even get the guys crazy
there's a beautiful scene at the top
where you know when bradley cooper first
comes to the carnival he sits down with
willem dafoe
and william defoe is explaining how
carnivals run and more importantly like
they got a geek
and uh how they keep the geek under
control geek for those that are like
what is that other than like you know
i'm a film geek true meaning of the term
geek the circus term or the carnival
term is uh you bite
the head off of a live chicken or a live
animal but predominantly chicken so
you're this man beast they bill you as
covered in filth and you know barely
human and they'll throw a live chicken
at you and you'll bite its head off and
people were paying like a nickel or
whatever [ __ ] to watch that because you
know like just like today people love to
watch [ __ ] reality tv
back then they were like that was our
kardashians this [ __ ] would bite
a chicken's head off and it was nuts and
that was our friday night
but you know
traditionally
i always assumed that the
geek in the circus
was like there willingly same as the fat
lady same as the hairy guy yeah and you
know it was just like well that's his
thing part of the show yeah and also
like when the show is done he's like hey
man so what are we doing today guys
exactly
here he's depicted as
practically a [ __ ]
human trafficked prisoner
who um is there
trapped essentially and like is
the the one uh geek is moaning and and
trying to
like not escape but like
yeah he wants to die it looks like and
then bradley cooper is told like not to
interact with them and stuff they treat
this guy like an animal and willem dafoe
tells him like
you know it ain't
is not a pro you know how you make a
geek it's real simple yeah
you uh they come to you looking for a
job and you say you ain't got nothing
then you say well wait so you give them
a drink and uh you know in that drink
maybe there's a little something or
whatever the [ __ ] something that gets
them real hooked to it so that they're
gonna need that drink even more but
you're already dealing with addicts he
says
and then um
you know you go like you ain't gonna
work oh but there is one thing you know
temporarily we just
or we lost our geek you do it for like a
few days and then you know get you back
on your feet and then you could do
something else and yeah so they're like
uh
okay and slowly they back into it and
before they know it they're [ __ ]
trapped human
animals psych cage
so willem dafoe literally tells us this
in the first 15 minutes of the movie
yeah essentially telegraphs the end of
the movie but you you don't think about
it like i never once while he was
describing it was i'm a guy who writes
movies never once was it like this is
going to come back at the end yeah and
there he is bradley cooper at the very
end of the movie looking disheveled and
and very geekish and talking to another
carnival uh a guy who runs a carnival
played by what's as [ __ ] um oh yeah um
um the guy who's at eric brothers yeah i
was gonna say
he's amazing he's an amazing wonderful
actor but what's crazy is that that baby
is in the scene so it's almost like
enoch because he isn't enoch and the
bible is supposed to be like the
knowledge of god so it's almost like the
ba and he willing to foe even says like
it you know it's i follows you so it's
almost like full circle because he has
in in willem dafoe's office he has this
like
human baby
you know in a jar the you know which is
very dull which is very del toro thing
if you've seen devil's backbone in a
bunch of his other movies he loves
babies
but but uh it it appears again in this
uh um
the carnival
uh
office at the end he's like oh i bought
it from an old
carnival which presumably was the one
that well
willem dafoe was running and so uh you
know bradley cooper's in real bad shape
and
and uh he offers him a drink and he's
like i ain't got any work for you and
he's like
you know come and think of it oh
he's like there is
a position uh yeah we just lost our geek
and bradley cooper
it's temporary and he realizes he sees
it yeah like and remembers and he's now
gone full circle
and like children said before it
hauntingly he starts chuckling with real
[ __ ] bad teeth and looking real
terrible and [ __ ] me and what does he
say he goes mister i was born for it i
was born for it because he's like do you
think you can do that because mister
i was bored for it and it's like credits
oh dude and it's like that's the end of
the [ __ ] picture i could not [ __ ]
believe it we were like i turned to my
wife and i was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah to be fair i was like look that's
the movie i came to see i came to see
what happens next show me the bradley
cooper is the geek movie and [ __ ] but we
already watched it yeah essentially that
was the thing and there were moments
when he was interacting with the geek
that i was like
you know oh i wonder if that's
yeah you know is it
you thought it would be a running
storyline but it wrapped up within the
first 15 or 20. yeah and then you never
thought about it again until that moment
until he was in that guy's office and
you're like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] he put him back right where he
started we also see the flashback of how
because you know they set up the
character kind of sort of like oh this
guy's kind of reinventing himself
restarting his life but then we see the
flashback of him like basically killing
his father you're like oh this
motherfucker's been ruthless like from
the start in the get-go yeah yeah and
also um i just realized too the parallel
of the relationship between tony
collette and uh david uh what's his last
name uh who plays pete who plays the
where where um
stan gets all his he steals all his
strengths
their relationship if you look at that
they were straight there yeah yes um um
their relationship is kind of a preview
of what happens with him and molly yeah
that's true she's because uh tony
collette's like poor pete breaks my
heart yeah
you know so
it's a dark [ __ ] picture kids like
it's
amazing it's amazing
but i mean like
you know thank thankfully ma'am we're in
the era of the pandemic kind of still
yeah because then you could always be
like well you know like [ __ ] people
aren't going out to the movies and
that's why this movie you know didn't
find the audience the way it should have
it's going to trust me
it just didn't at the box office but
even in pre-pandemic times yeah
i you know could you
imagine you're like let's go see
nightmare alley get the popcorn
holy [ __ ] by the end of the movie you
just want to [ __ ] put a gun in your
mouth it is such a haunting
haunting dark picture
insanely well made
and i could not [ __ ] take my eyes off
of it yeah but like still
i was you know i mean of course
the question the answer to the question
who is this movie for
is anybody who appreciates great
filmmaking yeah that being said remove
that
who is this movie for you know what i'm
saying like who is going like
i know it'll cheer people up
time to put in my feel good movie
it's like it's like people that like
watch uh wreck him for a dream like i'm
like
like hey man good for you you know we're
like not just a watch record for a gym
though like oh i always that's my
favorite movie like i watch it on repeat
and it's like how the [ __ ] can you like
yeah god it was tough to get through ass
to ass once
i don't i don't know that i ever need to
go see see that again before i hit the
grave and should i go watch labyrinth
the same way ever again
that's so true oh my god um
the goblin king indeed i uh i highly
recommend if people because the thing is
like uh i feel bad as a yellow fan i
didn't go to see it immediately be you
know pandemic and everything
but i'm glad that i saw it in black and
white first and then in color because
there it's almost i don't want to say
they're two different movies but man
they definitely
i actually
i think it's because i was watching also
for the first time but i think the black
and white just felt like it felt more
like even more bleak right so it had
like it was just gorgeous like that
scene at the beginning where um he burns
the house and the flames are literally
white
you know like it's just like so
beautiful to look at um and then the
the the normal edition version is
gorgeous especially all the carnival
stuff like yeah did you notice like when
um it's basically when he goes inside
that tent what's cool i found out in the
q a is that that tent scene
they actually shot like inside like you
know um i mean i'm not it's not like i
don't know why i'm acting like a
surprise but it's so cool that they
actually have like this like fan like
making it look like it was like a storm
like this
yeah in
but it's so cool to see like it's
basically stan going into the depths of
hell because he goes through the mouth
of the devil no [ __ ] and then on the
other side it's like the skull and all
that stuff so eye protein that's true
yeah
there's a guy who's working like who's
putting in
i mean i guess you can't call him easter
eggs it's just part of the composition
of the shot it's it's like not him going
i'm gonna hide something he's like yeah
it's right in plain sight open your
[ __ ] eyes did you see uh crimson peak
yeah oh my god eon's back yeah crimson
peak there's the symbolism of the one
girl the pure girl being the butterfly
and the other girl being the moth and
there's literally a shot when they're
about to have a confrontation there's a
jar in the background of a moth eating a
butterfly so stuff like that you're like
holy [ __ ] you know um
yeah uh you have you seen kronos
way back in like 94. yeah yeah yeah cool
yeah i i you could tell like a lot of
like the
the religious aspects of it like you
know i love there's one line in the
movie i'm probably not going to say it
right but he's like because it's the
whole movie is about like del toro's
take on vampirism
and uh how basically this one guy this
one sick guy who's lost all his organs
because he has cancer he's basically
trying to find immortality
so um there's this little device that
has a bug in it there's a lot of insect
uh
stuff in all his movies but in this
movie it's like this little bug that
lives inside a device that basically
once you hook cook it up to yourself and
like kind of but you have to then
consume human blood
to you know but anyways going back to it
there's there's a guy who wants the
device and he says like who's say he
says who's to say uh
jesus wasn't an insect the insects are
the most like you know perfect
creatures in the animal kingdom you know
i just love that lie it's great uh but
anyways where are you on shape of water
oh i love it and it's funny it's funny
because it's i think he wanted such a
beautiful movie oh it's gorgeous and i
think he originally wanted to do that
movie in black and white so that's why
i'm like it doesn't surprise me to see
that you know he did this night he did
nightmare alley did a version i mean
universal was smart they would just be
like hey you want a monster universe
give it to the electoral right jesus i
mean like why they were [ __ ] around
going like let's
have uh you know the these highbrow tony
folks just give them all to him he seems
to like yeah all those characters he's
he's done his versions
of of
all of them to some degree yeah
frankenstein he's done the vampire he's
done the creature um
yeah oh my god dude i would love to
because i know he said that he wants uh
doug jones to play the creature oh [ __ ]
yeah so and frankenstein's one of my
all-time favorite i guess it would be
you know what like if if they gave him
the universal monsters it'd be kind of
redundant at this point yeah except for
frankenstein if they were like that's
like
give him give him that one the
granddaddy yeah yeah no and um there's
actually the best version of
frankenstein i've ever seen is played by
luke goss is the bbc one that's like
four hours long and luke gaz is also a
del toro alumni he played uh the reaper
prince and blade two and then he played
the prince again in uh hellboy too oh
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] look at you man [ __ ] a
deep cut
um so i came here i know you came loaded
for bear it was uh children had uh
texted me he's like hey man i've been
listening to film school fridays and
he's like if you ever want to do
guillermo del toro i was like i do as a
matter of fact i would love to talk
about nightmare alley yeah um
february 1st i believe it is it's going
to be on hbo max kids and um you know i
think probably before that or around
that time it'll be transactional or if
it isn't already
or i doubt it is um
it will be soon so like you can check it
out on itunes or whatever [ __ ] but
do check it out just don't like base
your weekend on it you know just don't
be like this is my saturday night
make it your saturday afternoon because
you're gonna need a few hours afterwards
to digest and clean your soul
um because it is a movie about human
darkness and
and
there's
is there a single good character like a
moral character i guess rooney comes
close but even she's a [ __ ] lion
he tried to save rooney mara
i guess yeah
i guess there's a purity there of sorts
yeah man it's uh
it's it's quite a motion picture and i
don't want that to sound like facetious
or something where it's like oh he can't
say no nice about it i could say plenty
nice about it and i think i have
but
i can't think of another movie that has
stuck with me as much as that movie
stuck with me this year yeah so even
though it didn't like take the box
office by storm i can see it
back dooring into all the awards this
year um you know i'm not saying it's
gonna win but
i think you're gonna see this movie and
him
nominated a lot more i i think right now
like i said today i believe it
like there was a costuming award that it
got nominated for and and there was a
production design awards got nominated
for it so
i think it's you're gonna see
it as a contender coming up are they
still doing like 10 [ __ ] movies for
best picture i don't know if they are
this is definitely i stopped watching a
long time ago and actually when
guillermo won that one year i was like
oh
no oh [ __ ] quick turn on yeah and now
turn it back up so yeah um yeah there's
a if if they're still doing 10 [ __ ]
movies there's no way this does not get
nominated a he's an alumnus you know
who's won before but b this movie like
really
it does stand out it's it's it's an
auteur film like you can see the
filmmaker
all over it for heaven's sakes and um
and
you know it also has a hollywood
pedigree like the movie's been done
before and hollywood loves a remake yeah
i can see
him like uh surprising a bunch of people
like
more people are about to interact with
this movie than have for the last month
or something like that if anything if
anything i'm not religious but like this
is almost as good as going to church and
you know because you feel after after
the movie you're like man i'm not going
to [ __ ] sin yeah like i'm going to be
a good person yeah you try to clean up
your [ __ ] act instantly you're just
like look how do i avoid sitting in some
dude's [ __ ] office with him offering
me a drink going like it's temporary
it's a temporary job biting chicken sets
off yeah um
fall down uh the uh the the the path of
nightmare alley kids uh as it comes your
way uh the next week on uh on on home
video and hbo max and i think it's
playing the black and whites playing in
select theaters now it was in the life
or just in l.a for a while but now it's
going to be going out into different
cities so you can catch in black and
white catching black and white um the
excellent [ __ ] tips there man and in
a theater no less for sure yeah um yeah
i wonder if they'll do the black and
white version like yeah
video probably like a month later part
of me is like are they going to release
it as a special feature or going to do a
whole like a different release i'll buy
both
i say [ __ ] them i'm going to take my tv
i'm going to turn the color down to
black and white i'm just going to watch
that pucker in black and white my way
yeah
um the movie kids is nightmare alley the
filmmaker is the great
uh guillermo del toro man and uh here
talking about it have been uh me uh your
student kevin smith
and children [ __ ] you bought a lot of
[ __ ] guillermo del toro gdt
information not to make it worth your
time man so it was well worth the
[ __ ] time where can they interact
with uh your [ __ ] and [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] uh everything on social media
chogrin uh website children.com uh
currently um
your toy will be available soon the the
guru series there's a one of guillermo
called guru del toro there's uh i have a
children's book bilingual children's
book called kit del toro and um yeah the
guru sku and the mall rats will be
coming out later this year as i was
telling kevin before we started the
podcast this is i just turned 37 this is
my kevin smith year
he's absolutely right and the [ __ ]
thing he's working on right now and
almost done with is the the uh viewers
cute card for clerks three oh my gosh
all right well he redid uh the clown and
he was like um do you have a logo for
the movie yet and i was like no you want
to do it and
it came together within two or three
days yeah i i still i won't believe it
until i see it
we're mixing the movie
uh now so i think i see it was today
wednesday or tuesday yesterday's
wednesday's wednesday so tomorrow
um i see playback of reels like one
through four
that reel with the logos and stuff is
real zero so we got a few more days but
um
like it's yeah it's space is being held
for it already since you set it up i
want to like give a shout out to my uh
buddies over at matt cg is that who's
doing it what is it called the company
uh matt cg they're in quito ecuador uh
it's a studio that i'm actually uh
working with uh they animated my uh my
first short film that i wrote and
directed called lucky brave sunshine
[ __ ] hey are you done with it uh we
we will be done with it because we gotta
start submitting it to festivals in
february is that when the february
february is the submission yeah the big
one is a anisee in france so how long is
this short uh
seven minutes eight minutes with credits
and it's like cg it's all ce yeah yeah
it's based it's based on my own
childhood stuff and it's basically a
space western coming of age
and you drew it in 2d and then handed it
to somebody and said make this 3d or did
you do it did you have
how does that work uh i uh well i always
i knew that
uh working in an industry and making
connections and stuff with people i know
that i always wanted to kind of go back
to my roots and
give back in a way or work with you know
talent because you know a lot of places
around the world are not la you know so
um i saw this one short uh uh called
after work um uh done by the studio and
i saw they were from ecuador and i was
like immediately i was like i actually
didn't have an idea at the time of for a
short but i was like i'll make one
just to work with these guys and um my
co-director his name is ichi aguilar and
he uh he's kind of been you know also a
great mentor and i've learned a lot from
him even though i've worked in the
animation industry for the last 10 years
you know writing and directing your own
thing is is a wholly
completely different beast so um i've
learned a lot and looking forward to
making more [ __ ] so we'll see fingers
crossed and uh can i man he's on fire
kids the uh
the name is children
and you can find where do you have a
where's the where do you send people uh
children.com and uh instagram uh all
social media just children c-h-o-g-r-i-n
um
do you tell him you have a secret
identity or no oh yeah i mean
it's it's i can say that my name uh uh
it comes from two words i will leave it
there
um thank you for coming on talking up uh
the great uh g-d-t ladies and gentlemen
guillermo del toro
um that
uh is film school fridays [ __ ] i don't
even know how i signed these things off
something about like maybe the belt
uh oh class dismissed
but wait i should
we should say our names um for film
school fridays i'm kevin smith i'm joe
green class dismissed there you go
[Music]
this has been a smodco internet
production
sip
only at smodcast.com
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask of anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith